courtney ross had been in a relationship
with george floyd for nearly three years
by the time he died
for what i would call mama's boy i could
tell
from the minute i met him and the
emotion of testifying at the trial of
the man accused of killing him
was clear
they'd met when he worked as a security
guard at a salvation army shelter
he said
[Music]
it was so sweet at the time
both though had developed addictions to
opioids during their relationship
the lawyer for derek chauvin asked her
about taking george floyd to hospital
two months before his death you spent
several days with him at the hospital
correct
yes and did you learn
what that what caused that overdose no
at that time frame did you learn that mr
floyd was taking anything other than
opioids
no
you did not know that he had taken
heroin at that time
no two weeks before his death she said
she became aware he was using opioids
again
i noticed a change in his behavior yes
the defense claimed george floyd died of
a drug overdose
not a police officer's knee on his neck
the jury heard the paramedics who
responded that day testify
as to what they found i checked for a
pulse
and um did you also check
the individual mr floyd's pupils i did
and what did you determine at that point
they were large dilated you didn't feel
or detectable did not detect balls
and what did his condition appear to be
to you
overall in late terms i thought he was
dead
among those listening in court
throughout the trial have been members
of george floyd's family
his brother told sky news what it's been
like to relive his death
devastating having to relive it all over
again
it's like an emotional roller coaster
stuff is just constantly running through
your mind you have to relive
anything and everything you hear him
constantly
screaming because he's being tortured to
death and he's gasping for air like a
fish out of water
it's been an exhaustive at times graphic
examination of the events of that day
difficult for everyone involved and a
country
watching intently